ciao ragazzi allora questo nuovissimo
video io sono già in prima a natale i
video parla di natale particolare di
outfit
ho già il primo outfit perché non sono
riuscita a resistere al troppo bello
e però prima di far rivedere gli altri
out with volevo salutare elisa macrì lei
ieri i saltelli e modica riletta un
bacione a tutte e tre se volete far
risaltare il prossimo video ricordatevi
seguire le istruzioni che troverete
amati vedi questo video
ma bando alle ciance e passiamo noi
allora magari dice chietino e stato
bello ma per adesso della nostra storia
finisce qui partiamo subito con il primo
a jean condiviso questo video in vari
gruppettini appunto con un hashtag a
seconda del colore o del tessuto
eccetera eccetera dei vestiti che vi
hanno proporre questo chiaramente fa
parte de i rossi allora lo so è un po
esagerato e un po bello carico come
piace a me infatti non lo consiglio per
la cena magari coi pagamenti però magari
per un dopo cena magari per andare a
ballare e fare i balletti nella mariah
carey a jean todt cioè proprio lui il
vestito della vita hanno approvato e
sempre nei rossi c'è un modello un
pochino più sobrio ve lo faccio vedere
ed ecco a voi la seconda opzione dei
rossi allora sicuramente più semplice
sicuramente meno impegnativo ma comunque
falso tiburon e ovviamente il rosso è il
colore della quale per eccellenza ma ce
n'è un altro che è molto molto usato sto
parlando
adoro e non c'è nero per adesso è solo
da toro che il colore diciamo proprio
anche insieme al rosso classico del
natale
ed è questo vestito il giusto
compromesso tra berluschino maganza
perché non è per forza boro sinonimo di
esagerazione di poca sobrietà ci può
anche se una via di mezzo e questa per
me è la perfetta via di mezzo
ma il natale è sì o rossi rosso ma c'è
anche un terzo colore che potrebbe
essere molto molto carino da utilizzare
per l'africa natale sto parlando
dell'argomento ed è subito argento e
questo il sito per l'omesso tra l'altro
io ho una tale l'ho fatto un po di anni
fa ed è molto carino perché un po più
pesano anch'io di quelli di prima quindi
se magari non siete proprio al mare
oppure in una casa super riscaldata
questo è un buon compromesso molto
carino cioè quest'anno poi questo
dettaglio della manica molto per non
dire anni 70 e dopo l'argento c'è il
velluto il velluto per eccellenza è
super invernale ma anche super da sera
insomma non mettere mai di tono
questa è la versione che li propongo
maniche lunghe quindi per le frettolose
di sopra modi sotto perché complete
vedere abbastanza corta
bordeaux melanzana insomma quel colore
lì che mi piace molto e tra l'altro
stesso colore delle unghie quindi è
proprio il mio mi sa che lo metterò
questo natale ma se non vi piace il
bordo c'è il verde subito folletto vi
piace vi adoro
tra l'altro questo vestito l'ho usato
tipo tanti anni fa per un natale
ovviamente per andare a ballare non ho
messo la cei natale però avuto molto
successo molto bello io trovo molto
molto originale per cambiare un po nel
senso to parte così alla fine sempre
rosse però se un anno vogliamo uscire un
po dalle righe mettiamoci il verde
folletto allora fino adesso vi ho fatto
vedere soltanto vestitini magari a
quelli di voi non hanno voglia mettere
vestito hanno freddo preferiscono un
completo oppure stare più comodo e
quindi vi offrirò anche delle diverse
opzioni per esempio dell'abbinamento di
un top e di un pantalone vediamolo
subito ed ecco voi
l'abbinamento insomma più diretto di
farvi vedere ma è molto libro diciamo
che delle opzioni che ho proposto questo
è il più intercambiabile perché perché
io ho messo vanta cos'altro argentato e
appunto troppo nero con questo
particolare qua delle maniche ma poi
potete interpretarla come volete
nel senso quello che vi consiglio è
magari dopo il pantalone metterlo di un
colore magari natalizio magari e punto
che iterato eccetera eccetera
metallizzato insomma uno dei due a mio
parere potrebbe essere un po meno sobrio
diciamo un corpo perché natale l'altro
penso qui viola la parte di sopra po il
pantalone potrebbe essere un gene
potrebbe essere un pantacollant
antognoni pelle quello che volete
insomma quello che mi consiglio io vi
consiglio è semplicemente avere una
delle due cose e metterlo bello
sberluccicante e natale una volta sola
all'anno no non mi sentivo di far finire
questo video senza proporvi un opzione
diciamo che a noi donne spesso serve sto
parlando della upi che io magari
consiglierei alle più freddolose io per
prima faccio parte insomma del gruppo
delle freddolose ma diciamo che a natale
di solito preferisco soffrire un pochino
il freddo ma magari beccarmi investito
top mi piace un sacco e e battere i
denti tanto dura 2 3 ore
la cena ci si cambia e si va col pigiama
rifai sotto le docce passero e quindi
all ultima categoria cioè i frettolosi
dividere i frettolosi in due outfit il
primo è stata di nuovo argento quindi in
realtà non e frettolosi ma è freddoloso
argento e poi vedremo secondo quindi
maglione bello carino sobrio argentato e
pantacollant di velluto
voi potete ciclo che volete anche gli
belle qualsiasi cosa io mi era in nero
passiamo al secondo outfit della
categoria freddolosi l'ultimo pit che vi
propongo non poteva che essere oro nero
quindi ricapitolando questo è freddoloso
oro oro nero oltre a stone e direi che
può bastare come
ha sempre un outfit è uguale a quello di
prima ma il mancino è leggermente più
corto qui arriva proprio giusto a filo
coi pantaloni ed è chiaramente oro non
ho ancora deciso esattamente la fit per
natale ma diciamo che questo è in lizza
per il prescelto
questi sono gli outfit che mi sento di
consigliarvi per questo natale
in questo video non avete chiesto in
tanti quindi spero di aver consigliato a
ciascuno di voi la bit giusto per lo
meno avrei fatto venire in mente qualche
idea
fatemi sapere qui sotto qual è il vostro
preferito e magari se lo userete per per
le vostre feste
detto questo come al solito vi ricordo
se volete essere salutati dal prossimo
video che dovrete fare semplicemente
questi tre step quindi seguirmi su
instagram scrivere un direct con scritto
il vostro nome e mi farebbe piacere
salutati e aspettare il prossimo video
per vedere se se mi faccio col video più
belle anche e soprattutto se non l'avete
ancora fatto iscrivetevi al mio canale
non dimenticatevi seguire anche sugli
altri social news i pali e facebook ciao
a tutti e buon natale